oh hello and our welcome another honest
trailer commentary hello we're talking
about knives out today starring a Benoit
Blanc
Dana Craig and his deepest fried
molasses voice I say yes a fun film that
I think we all enjoyed but we still make
fun of it so if you're watching this
show you get to hear about our true
uncensored thoughts on the movie stick
around you'll see some deleted scenes a
little tease for next week's honest
trailer and responses to comments and
questions Joestar is in the deep south
Daniel Radford for a month on a new
radical congratulations as realistic as
Daniel Craig's I love this movie this is
a very cartoonish foghorn leghorn would
look at that and be like oh do you think
is it possible that Benoit Blanc is
purposefully putting on a crazy accent
to like throw people off is that do you
think that's in the realm of possibility
or is it no it's just a very high world
that they live in everything in this
world is very heightened and that you
know I thought yeah I understand the
people that were not on board I was very
much on board as a fan of Daniel Craig's
gonzo wacky performances because he
could be a little bit of a pill
sometimes on screen like James Bond he's
been very sedate lately
I like when he's in a movie that lets
him just be kind of weird crazy voice
over the top I feel like he's just like
feels so free when he's not in the bomb
suit that he feels like he has to go up
to eleven with every comedic part yeah
but just because he has so much pent-up
rage having
I mean I just think there is there's
also a thread in the movie of like the I
don't know like a Columbo he's like a
wacky it's actually not very savvy in
terms of like the genius detective
consultants like it's Sherlock Columbo
3:3 through 17 yeah it's true yeah so
yeah what else do we have to say about
this film that's not covered in this
thing this is tougher one because the
good movies are hard to do but at the
same time it was one that people a saw
be liked yes he wanted which is
whodunits don't get made or seen very
often I guess murder on the owner
expressed express yeah and there's gonna
be death on the Nile this year and the
Benoit Blanc spin-off supposedly right
yeah it's coming years I feel like that
and the endless Sherlock remakes or more
a factor of them just being public
domain' stories lock is different
Sherlock like Sherlock is the star of
the show whereas I feel like these
ensemble pieces like yes the detective
is sort of the central figure but it's
also about yeah all of these it's also a
good way it's it's a new original story
with new original characters but it is
still a formula that people know so
there is still that element of
familiarity which was where you can run
into trouble it can be hard to mark it
like a totally original story sometimes
because people want to know what they're
getting into you know what you're
getting into with done it it's like even
if the situation's are different it's
we're gonna meet a big any one of them
we're gonna all be in the parlor at the
end right yeah still know what you're
getting yeah yeah all right well let's
watch the knives out be honest trailer
yeah not the woman in the movies reading
is reading PES for spoilers it's okay
I'm just gonna disappear for a moment
yeah okay you can roll the trailer I'll
just well I'm oh don't we have to do
that okay there we go a little bit of a
delay an iPhone's sustainer from the
director who ruined your man childhood
comes a film about how if you act like
an entitled dick women and minorities
will take away everything you ever loved
no not that one the new one and mute
thread Rian Johnson mm-hmm
themes to his work or is it just a
coincidence I think that we are doing
the thing that we do where we take a
similarity and you know simplify it for
comedic effect
I think his I think is the similarity at
all of his work is that he wants to take
something that you know and twist it
right different yeah
from brick to looper to last Jedi to the
to fly fly the that episode of Breaking
Bad first time I ever heard anyone
bitched and moaned about Rian Johnson
was that fly episode yeah because it was
so different and weird and what's going
on you know and but then he wouldn't
also directed many other great episodes
so I think he likes to take something
and and it's it's we've overused it but
subvert your expectations and do
something unexpected yeah and well so I
think that this film he was more vocal
with the things that he doesn't like him
it annoys him then really any of his
movies before like you can tell in this
one more than any other waiting about
stuff he gave himself this like Greek
chorus of awful like he's got this
family he's establishing that they're
jerks there
role in the film is to be these kind of
rich [ __ ] and so I think he's kind
of using them like he can put anything
in their mouths but it got to the point
where some of them are just complaining
about like Netflix streaming anything I
have these characters say it's like I'm
making fun of it without having to come
out and say yeah hey I don't like this
thing yeah it wasn't that
straightforward for me though I felt
like he died he hid it under a very what
I thought was a very clever layer of
they think they're good people like when
they would you know like oh we love
Marta but no one knew where she was from
or like when Don Johnson just like
handed her the plate
you know after talking about how much he
loved her or you know everyone going I
was like I wanted you at the funeral but
I was outvoted just this idea of like
these people who are just they're just
a-holes like just nasty people and
they'll do or say anything like it
didn't seem quite as on-the-nose as I
think a lot of people may have found it
to me I think it's really you're just
telling the story about these people
that are just they're awful people just
really the worst people it's still
there's there's levels to it you know
some of them are they think they're good
people and they're awful and I just
don't really care about how they come up
but they're all greedy and self-serving
on like once you get right down yeah
yeah I just felt like you know that a
lot of people said like well the movie
gets into the political ideology of them
you know because you know cuz they think
you know they talk about immigration and
stuff like to me like part of the point
was there were also characters who were
like above it and we're just like oh
you're awful but then they were just as
terrible as everyone else so to me it
was more about how like awfulness knows
no real ideology even if people think
that they do or they think that well I
believe this so I can't be a terrible
person like I think the point of it was
like no you're just as big of an eight
holes that person you just you think
that because they think this way you're
not in a hole or they or none you know
it's just no you're just awful you're
terrible people in general you're awful
every flavor of a hole was represented
in this film alright let's keep going
dives out
get ready for a brand new whodunit
murder mystery but since Roger never met
an expectation he couldn't subvert he'll
tell you who done it right off the bat
plus where it got did and how it get
done then slowly reveal who helped done
it
who done knew about it and why it all
got getting done in the first place it's
more of a how done they get away with it
really I asked is the lair the cable
guide to much and no one said no so
there yes just write the most
appropriate use of the Cable Guy okay
good good I'm glad it passed yeah it's
gonna fit on a marquee that's a good
point
thank you yeah so yeah like you said it
is he likes he likes twisting what you
think you're getting one thing that
didn't make it in but I thought ran
throughout is the madness that everyone
seems to realize they're in a mystery
movie mmm-hmm everyone makes a lot of
dialogue choices that's like I hope that
ending has a big flourish so it starts
with Harlan thrombi lives in a house
that is like a murder house that's based
on his mystery novels they just the fact
that it's taking place in a set
seemingly established for a murder
mystery to happen in which is kind of a
trope that they've taken from sleuth
yeah there's that 70s movie sleuth that
they remade Michael Caine's in both
versions and that's also about a guy
like the the person who the crime
happens around is obsessed with murder
mysteries and already lives in this
house with all kinds of like secret
pathways and compartments and so it's
you know like murder mysteries happening
to people who are already fascinated
with murder Mis just like the as I've
surmised from several 15-second promos
also the plot of Castle
okay isn't he like a detective he's a
writer who registered he's a writer who
uses his influence I Mar as a huge fan
of cast he's a writer who uses his
influence to tag along on cases with
this detective but you know of course he
gets involved and gives us his write
early knowledge it's ostensibly research
but he you know and he's like tied up
like you started with is you know like
everyone has bulletproof vests to say
police and his says writer on it that's
funny yeah yes he tags along you don't
suffer it's the same set up as Lucifer
he's Satan but he tags along with the
LAPD while they solve murders that's
true I swear that's I'm not making that
up that's something so Lucifer's event
this is like that it was get what is
Burn Notice so crime way twice he's the
devil he's dead because he likes this
one lady copies his entire primal nature
because he has a crush on a cop because
if you think about it like he's still
going after sinners you just did this
slick
[Music]
[Applause]
he's doing good to do for questions do
the world's most sumptuous sweater
collection and imagine that looks like
an Applebee's themed escape room their
patriarch is Christopher Plummer
the best actor to ever get typecast as
the wealthy head of a miscarriage family
when his suicide is ruled a murder
everyone is a suspect because he spent
the night giving his entire family
reasons to kill him last money dad are
you firing me
Haarlem of cleaning house not a dime or
word of my work to a single one of them
you included me come on man don't you
know cutting off your relatives is the
number two cause of death and rich
people see right behind ya I think he
wanted to die he didn't mind I certainly
didn't mind he had he had the whole plot
right there right there ready to go just
in case something like his medication
getting switched well did do the thing
of like he cut off the entire family and
he is a murder mystery writer so he
probably have suspected perhaps that
someone might try to bump him off it's
more than suspect it's like he was
trying to it's weird that he tells
ransom that
giving he's leaving the money to Marta
because that does seem to also put a
target on her yeah like Chris Chris
Evans only initiates his plot because he
knows that he's got a frame Marta so
that she doesn't inherit his money when
he dies right I think that wouldn't have
happened if he just said like I'm giving
it to charity
like nice well I guess the money was
really tied up in like the film rights
was that what it was like no it's the
publishing the publishing is where the
real money is and then Michael Shannon's
like we could make a lot more yeah cuz
Netflix wants to adapt the books he's
like if I can't make movies out of my
books that wouldn't be an issue I'm
Michael Shannon was the head of the
company right now they have a sense of
how much the authors make does like
Raymond Chandler have like a billion
dollars but Stephen King does yeah I
mean they're not making Raymond Chandler
movies like if you are getting adapted
all the time like sure yeah I'm sure I
think what they're saying it's like they
have a very nice family fortune from
writing yeah it'd be like a Stephen King
like you probably made several million
dollars from his books movies money has
he gotten from selling rights if he had
built up 30 years of bestsellers that
had never been adapted and all of a
sudden you could start making all these
movies out of and all that Stephen King
merch you know yeah under the dome dome
any white shirt orange shirts shining
Maximum Overdrive I'll drop scary pig's
blood buckets you know there's more
there's more Stephen King works than
you'd think
I'll bet yeah all right I don't know how
much cc's of that but we've got a
needful things opening at the Grove
Court I have a legal years
thermos is my favorite thing in the
world taking Bernie says Benoit Blanc a
detective who could really use a fidget
spinner idle hands advice at first
course other than a confederate flag
soaked in deep fried mint juleps the
other alts we had for that we're Moore's
other than deep fried sweet tea or Morse
other than monogrammed corn bridge minor
grams it's a southern thing is to like
have your initials on your sylvan where
it also like a very northeastern maybe
out club type monogram pajamas or
whatever yeah yes i think it's generally
AFK ahead pajamas hot okay i almost
promise you JFK head pajama thing it's
just like a posh thing as opposed to uh
well there you go we want the
confederate flag
deep fried mint julep yeah Confederate
fab like deep-fried yeah genteel tobacco
cornbread we'd be like alright well da
for the cap to y'all let's give you a
juleps but don't underestimate this
simple country detective because he's so
good he doesn't know who's paying him
who are you I do not know does an
interview keep witnesses for days I
think you have something you want to
tell me
and that's the main suspect almost died
in his care going twice
you'll need all the help from Barda
career he also doesn't dust for prints
he gets the money and we see a flashback
of Chris Evans sending him the money
without wearing gloves or anything like
him
Oh case would just be if you found Chris
Evans prints on the envelope well and
and I saw some push bags like well he
knew he saw the blood on Marta's shoes
so he knew she was involved from the
beginning like well first of all maybe
could have been he could be at loss oh
yeah you see the blood in the shoe and
you can surmise that she is involved she
was she was present owners who jabs an
old man in the arm yeah so maybe there's
another explanation for that we say in a
few seconds in the trailer but like I
feel like the movie would be over and
granted that's why we have movies it was
be boring otherwise but he can get her
in a room and asked 20 questions and the
throwing up thing seems like a really
unfair in any cop to be like I know
you're a human lie detector I'm just
gonna ask you the following yes-or-no
question this was a sherlock episode he
would literally walk in and have like
the one question to ask her that
wouldn't solve the whole thing is the
guy to your left lying right if I were
to say that he was the killer would I be
incorrect
that's why it's not a short film yeah
okay Keep Calm a nurse with a rare form
of bulimia just the thought of lyin it
makes me puke a condition that any good
detective could use to crack the case in
30 seconds
but this half-cocked Sherlock can't even
smell the lies right in front of him you
mean my smell oh yeah you know I say for
a film called knives out this uh
detective yard is about as sharp as a
bowling ball
Buster's a-holes and Agatha Christie
ride along with the silly fun not really
a mystery where everyone's a red herring
and the most famous guy helped do it in
the end really the only question you
have is how one housekeeper kept an
entire mansion full of knickknacks
secret passages and hidden piles of
nurse pew clean yet more plot holes from
ruined Johnson ashtec remake knives out
with more puke cleanup scenes the maid
had a bunch of pre-rolls in a clock
thank God for those do because they
weren't there then the whole the whole
thing would have gone up in forgets that
both marijuana and puke smell where is
the maid smoking these doobs that no
one's noticing they're all the time
she's throwing up everywhere and then
just like covering it with lids and
putting things back
leave it for Fran somewhere yeah break
for breeze around you got to do
something very inconsiderate yeah okay
good point let's go go did he's a good
point
better call draw you need to spew spew
into this that is America's box all it's
gonna take this house from the Oh frown
stroller trash bridges Michael K inherit
Harry will Frank Oz the great and
powerful get out get out old Deuteronomy
and Kevin Spacey positive as a fun fact
that the woman playing Christopher
plumbers mother is seven years younger
than if they like
so old she can't even speak or move is
younger than plumber yeah we made her up
you know yeah yeah I think she
definitely looks like Judi Dench as a
cat hatsan first she could be anything
from the big glasses yeah and this is a
reference to of course um we call the
movies where he's the head of a rich sad
family and last-minute reshoots replaced
the space with plum they get an Oscar
nom out of it yeah yeah for fastest
acting fastest yeah there's that one
scene in the desert where it's obviously
the throw up of green screen in the
parking lot but there's apparently I've
never picked it out apparently there is
one scene where he's in the background
and it is still Kevin Spacey and see
they didn't have time to reshoot it yeah
okay let's finish this one the last P i
if Harlan wanted to kill himself while
clearing Marta of any suspicion why
didn't he do it in front of anyone else
in a house full of people
you know what ended the movie early
that's why a short film yeah haha let's
see some scenes we have any oh yeah you
think we did just a story welcome Dan
Craig the inspector tangent the South
was surmise again nurses foiled again
Gossip Girl
I say hurl if you put chunks and he
comes back the house is yours
if you spew in their boat then it was
never meant to be Gilmore Girls
killing Steve huge as Oreo untrue lies
kneel before Claude okay make sense in
hereditary hashtag in Oscar for Tony oh
yeah
shut up Meg it's a Megalodon he lighted
do it boy definitely hated tlj Jacob
wool
when Johnson needs to leave this
franchise book-smart neck slits and will
mr. Boddy liquid plumr Agatha Christie
stupid is as stupid does lieutenant
stand death knows a cat is not a dog out
the knives are cleaver sandiana Mr piggy
knives out is brought to you by the
letter L and M is for money that you
don't be getting random house schmuck
session
eat the rich brawl in the family maniac
mansion knives she made Robert narrow
and he's down we did i bolded the ones
that we were that we wanted but he did
them all there's to be a filter we've
changed the way we dude I'm gonna get we
have to be a filter because you can't
tell them which ones to do because he's
so good whatever you give them they'll
do just need to only give them the ones
we love to do we'll discuss this will
give you the viewer of this show like
that's three hours everyone that's three
hours of Robert whole B's life I always
doubt editors when they talk about
rendering he's not an editor he's a
graphic design but the time crunch is
always in rendering I feel like if I
were an editor or a graphic designer I
would always just say I've this
rendering have you anything to render in
your life it is the most aching tedious
tiny needs it takes forever that's the
thing that sucks is you're technically
you're doing something but you can also
do nothing mmm unless you're on two
completely different systems rendering
is the devil and never
question I spent three hours thinking of
schmuck sessions it's an even share of
labor that yes good times there's also
one other super we thought I'm gonna
guess USA Netflix they was on Fox and
then it got canceled and then Netflix
moved it over and Asia because
characters are well we're gonna do one
other tag that was like and now I'm
gonna run off in this direction at speed
[Applause]
okay
[Music]
rest in your brain Alexandra Tripel
writes so did we like Daniel Craig's
acting or was it too over-the-top I
agree with Dan this is a heightened film
and he was playing a heightened
character there were only a few moments
where it wasn't that he was laying it on
too thick it's that the thickness like
modulated too much like sometimes he
would be sometimes he would just have
regular not perfectly consistent but
there's a long tradition in these kinds
of movies of even if the ensemble is
more realistic the detective character
can do you know like like a Hercule
Poirot kind of person where he'll be
surrounded by just boring English people
but he's got the Belgian accent and the
crazy mustache and like it's he's the
heightened figure so I think it's sort
of a nod to that so I liked it yep then
you need that pen okay Jamel Johnson
writes a question for the commentary how
far into the movie did you figure out
which white person did it I mean the
movie tells you he killed himself
yeah like right off the bat and it's
like who helped him or who engineered
yeah what were the circumstances that
led to this sort of situation yeah I
mean I think that's one thing I liked
about the movie is that you know usually
like when it's more straight ahead
mystery like here's 20 characters which
one of them is the killer it feels
almost like you can't really keep up
like there's clues that it could be
anybody and then at the end you figure
out who it was and this I feel like
you're in the game with this movie more
like you're maybe not totally keeping up
but you're only ever a step or two
behind you where the detective is where
the movie wants you and like that was
nice I enjoyed feeling like I was
keeping up with white person did it
there's that was all the suspects knew
where Margot was Marta was the only only
knew exactly where she was which
could've been putting on an act that she
oh whoops
I gave you the wrong bottle like that
could have been a misdirect yeah I would
have in the last scene she was like evil
and had planned out the whole I mean
that's something I skipped because it's
a very long comment or question
protip keep a little short then I'll
probably read it
but this someone brought up that like
maybe Marta's throwing up thing was a
was shtick was like yeah that'd be an
interesting when I lie and then she
could do she'd be like haha I puke
anytime Skokie Illinois it would be very
cheap because they don't end a
storytelling standpoint what I like
about the mystery genre is when you do
interviews and you hear about what
happened from a character you're seeing
their version of what happened
and so it's inherently subjective in the
sense that like if it's revealed later
on that something happened there that
was different than what they told it's
like these are suspects think it's
because it's an unreliable narrator
whereas I felt with Marta the movie
itself was very straightforwardly
telling you like this is what happened
and so I think it would feel very cheap
if later they were to be like oh no that
was a lie like I feel like that was the
movie presenting in a very objective way
I've done everything else it's like well
maybe it didn't happen that way because
this person can't be the key thing that
he does just in terms of the language of
the way the scene is directed is it's
not when we see the flashback to what
happened with her in the Attic with
varlyn we're seeing not the version
she's telling Benoit Blanc she's
remembering it as he coined because then
the memory ends he catches the coin so
that we know this isn't what she told
him right this is what is in her much
remembering and a fraud memory so I
think that's as far as storytelling goes
like that was the clue for me that Marta
didn't really have any kind of ill
intent because the the rules of
storytelling would dictate that if
you're gonna present it that way and
then it's alive and that's just cheap
bad storytelling it's a I was fooled by
when he has ransom befriend her and like
take her out for sausage and beans not a
thing
we call it up angles of lash like I
believed that he had subverted our
expectations that ransom wasn't a bad
guy and now was gonna be these two
solving the case together and there you
go
so I went for it finals that comments
are questioned by Anthony McNeil so who
did it again after watching this I still
don't know who well well Harlan thrombi
killed himself
right Marda believed that she had given
him an overdose of morphine but she did
not because ransom had switched the
medicines thinking that he was going to
cause Marta to give him an overdose so
in reality is very tragic thing where
they believed an overdose had occurred
but in fact it did not it's a very kind
of a tragedy yeah type thing and so yeah
so ransom killed the housekeeper and
tried to make Martha look responsible
for her instead and arranged for the
medical facility doing the blood work to
be blown up to cover his tracks
yes so there you go that's who that
boiler who done that's who did that's
who done a that's what happened all
right yeah
what are your genuine hopes for knives
out to do you hope it's this same
there's more carryover mark to the rest
of this family are just a blog to a new
room I think yeah you definitely do the
Poirot the you know like it's the next
case and the only thing that carries
over is the detective I also I like the
idea of like two-word I don't think it
should be knives out to I think it
should be something else like you know
whatever spoons up like whatever those
two-word phrase and then like if you
need to do like : a Benoit blog Mr
Forster utensil trilogy it just all
utensils II know but I think like an
alley you know noun verb you know
title and then : a Benoit blood mystery
I definitely go to see now in virtue but
out is a add is it an adverb isn't an
adjective knives out out to herb it's no
it's a preposition right yeah yeah out
yeah preparation right Frank Castle of
these to get all this speech what do you
hope knives out to it's called sound off
the comments below and we hope you join
us back here same time same place next
week
hmm let's see all these ones are gonna
be really obvious so you know I hope you
don't go cold on us between now and then
and we'll see you then and we hope you
had fun and we'll see you one more time
next Wednesday is it Wednesday only one
more time all right
[Music]
you